und da sind wir meine Damen und Herren
genau zur richtigen Sekunde zurück im
Deutschen Bundestag den
Bundestagsvizepräsidentin ruft in dieser
Sekunde das haben wir auch schon lange
nicht mehr so schön präzise getroffen
die Aktuelle Stunde auf die hier
stattfinden wird auf Antrag der
Koalitionsfraktionen und die den Titel
trägt Proteste in China und deutsche
China Politik kann seiner fidge hat
einige entscheidende Punkte eben schon
angesprochen die Proteste in China
dauern an in einzelnen Regionen scheinen
sie auch zu eskalieren die staatsmachte
zeigt sich von ihrer oder versucht es
zumindest von ihrer stärksten Seite zu
zeigen das ist die eine Medaille oder
die eine Seite der Medaille das andere
ist eine China Strategie an der die
Bundesregierung arbeitet und die in
diesen Tagen und Wochen entstehen soll
und deswegen steigen wir jetzt ganz fix
in diese Debatte hier ein Jürgen Trittin
ist der erste Redner außenpolitischer
Sprecher der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen
nächstes das Symbol jener mutigen
Chinesinnen und Chinesen die sich nicht
mit der repressiven
kurve-politik von Ski weiter abfinden
wollen ich finde dieser Mut dieses
Selbstbewusstsein das verdient unser
Unterstützung unserer Respekt
kurz nach dem
pompösen 20 Parteitag steht die
kapichinas offensichtlich
in Legitimationsproblem denn es gab
Vorboten für diese Demonstration da gab
es jene Shanghai Nachbarn die losgezogen
sind nachdem sie monatelang eingesperrt
waren ohne Essen ihre benachbarte
kp-zelle zu verprügeln da gab es jene
Arbeiterinnen und Arbeiter die nachdem
sie ja wochenlang bei Fox kommen dem
Apple fertiger in der Fabrik gefangen
waren und produzieren mussten in den
Streik getreten sind und dafür von
Sicherheitskräften angegriffen worden ja
die KP hat mit leichten Lockerungen vor
kurzem der Zeit darauf gearbeitet aber
dieses beseitigt nicht die Ursache der
Unzufriedenheit denn die liegt viel
tiefer wir müssen heute feststellen
Chinas zerocover Politik ist gescheitert
es sind zu wenige Menschen geimpft und
gegen Omicron hilft eben es nicht weg zu
sperren und lockdowns zu machen
und
die corona-krise ist ja nicht das
einzige Problem in China ist eine
riesige immobilienbase geplatzt das
heißt Millionen Menschen drohen um ihr
Erspartes gebracht zu werden weil die
Wohnung für die Sie bezahlt haben nicht
gebaut werden inzwischen sind einige
dazu übergegangen ihre eigenen Wohnung
zu besetzen die nicht fertig gebaut sind
und die Folgen für China sind
Millionen WanderarbeiterInnen und
Wanderarbeiter sind arbeitslos geworden
und zurück in ihre Dörfer vertrieben
worden ein Fünftel der Jugendlichen
hofft hochqualifiziert im Ausland
studiert sind arbeitslos
und die Lieferketten sind und bleiben
gestört china hat das geringste Wachstum
in Asien Schlusslicht geworden mit
verheerenden Folgen auch für unsere
Wirtschaft denn die Lieferketten bleiben
gestört und in dieser Sackgasse
beschließt die chinesische Führung nicht
zu ändern sondern Vollgas zu geben dazu
gegen wird zu Recht auf begehrt und
dagegen brauchen wir eine neue
China-Politik selbstverständlich wir in
Europa können nicht ohne China aber wir
sollten gerade vor dem Hintergrund
dieser Vorgänge auch ganz ruhig
feststellen China kann auch nicht ohne
Europa ja eine stimmt das alte Dogma ob
man das nun Schröder oder Merkel
zuschreibt Wandel durch Handel ist halt
gescheitert
aber wir müssen uns klarmachen und zwar
nicht nur der Staat auch die Wirtschaft
dass Chinas Markt auf Dauer eben kein
verlässlicher Markt mehr ist das müssen
wir in unserer Strategie berücksichtigen
deswegen müssen wir dafür sorgen dass
wir souveräner das wir resilienter
werden deswegen ist es klug wenn viele
Unternehmen sagen wir wollen
diversifizieren wir wollen auch
Produktion zurückverlagern wir werden
selber dafür auch Geld in die Hand
nehmen müssen weil wir in Europa Chips
Produktion brauchen weil wir
rückverlagern müssen Pharma weil wir
rückverlagern müssen auch die
Photovoltaikindustrie die man eine
schwarz-gelbe Regierung nach China
vertrieben hat
aber es ist dann eben auch unklug die
eigene Abhängigkeit von China dadurch zu
erhöhen wie es vier große Unternehmen
gemacht haben die dafür alleine
verantwortlich sind dass die deutschen
Direktinvestitionen in China mitten in
der corona-krise gestiegen sind es ist
nicht klug auch wenn man Schwierigkeiten
hat zu diversifizieren die eigene
Abhängigkeit noch weiter zu vergrößern
und das ist der Grund warum diese
Regierung gesagt hat ihr tut das künftig
auf eigene Rechnung diese Investitionen
die garantieren wir euch nicht mehr wenn
ihr sie beispielsweise in Shinji antide
das tut ihr auf eigene Rechnung und ich
finde so geht eine
menschenrechtsbasierte
Außenwirtschaftspolitik
und schließlich
wir brauchen ein lieferkettengesetz wir
brauchen ein gesetzliches Verbot für den
Import von Produkten aus Zwangsarbeit
das muss unsere Antwort auf TGM things
angedrohte Repressionswelle sein und ich
will mal eine Bemerkung noch dazu machen
wer denn unbedingt
unter dem Weihnachtsbaum ein neues
iPhone aus der Fabrik von foxcorn haben
möchte
dann sage ich auch
Apple ist der Konzern
der dieser Tage seine erdrop-funktion
für China eingeschränkt hat
mit dieser erdrop-funktion konnten
Menschen Inhalte beispielsweise Videos
von Demonstrationen in öffentlichen
Verkehrsmitteln an andere weitergeben
diese Einschränkung gibt es nur in China
ich sage Ihnen
wer über den chinesischen Polizeistaat
schimpft der darf von Apple in diesem
Zusammenhang nicht schweigen
ist der außenpolitische Sprecher der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen und hat
die aktuelle Stunde zur Lage in China
und zur deutschen China Politik eröffnet
fünf Minuten Redezeit das ist das
Konzept der Aktuellen Stunde und die hat
jetzt Johann wadevogel an der
stellvertretenden Vorsitzenden der
Unionsfraktion in China miteinander
diskutieren weiß jetzt nicht ganz
Bewusstseinswandel bei der
Ampelkoalition der Grund dafür ist oder
mehr der taktische hintergrund ist dass
man die Aktuelle Stunde zu ihrer
Einbürgerungspolitik die wir beantragt
haben auf den morgigen Tag vertagen
wollte aber wie dem auch sei wir nehmen
das Angebot wahr und diskutieren Herr
Kollege die mit Ihnen gern wieder über
eine China Politik natürlich auch vor
dem Hintergrund dieser bemerkenswerten
Proteste die sie ein Kind beschrieben
haben und die ja in einem wirklich
frappierenden Gegensatz zu den
Entscheidungen der KP China stehen die
gerade sozusagen einige Tage zuvor für
einen Machtzuwachs in der Person von
Präsident schieb gesorgt haben wie wir
denen seit Mao zedrungen in diesem Land
nicht gesehen haben und das dennoch
dieses Regime auf Tönen in den Füßen
steht das haben die Proteste gezeigt und
sie da will ich Ihnen noch gar nicht
widersprechen der Kollege Trittin haben
das gerade eben noch einmal
nachgezeichnet das zeigt dieses Regime
ist vulnerabel zumindestens für einen
Moment und das bedeutet dass wir uns
positionieren können und müssen und dass
wir dazu auch eine Möglichkeit zum
Einwirken haben
voraussetzung dafür ist nur meine sehr
verehrten Kolleginnen und Kollegen dass
wir und das ist der Titel auch ihre
aktuellen Stunde dass wir eine
kohärente China Politik der
Bundesregierung haben und die sehen wir
nicht liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
denn die Rede Herr Kollege Trittin die
sie hier gehalten haben die Würde der
Bundeskanzler hier nie so halten der
steht offensichtlich für eine ganz
andere China-Politik
das hat seine Reise nochmal sehr
eindrücklich gezeigt eine Reise der
verpassten Chancen eine Reise des weiter
so würde man in ihrem Sinne sagen eine
Reise des Business as usual und das muss
ich an der Situation schon sagen wer in
der jetzigen Situation verkennt
das China sich massiv verändert dass
China sich immer mehr von einem
autoritären zu einem diktatorischen
System wandelt was internationale Regeln
nicht achtet sondern eine sinozentrische
Weltordnung errichten will und das
Deutschland sich gemeinsam mit
europäischen Partnern dazu positionieren
muss der erkennt die Zeichen der Zeit
nicht und das gilt für den Bundeskanzler
und insofern war
bemerkenswert die Kritik der
bundesaußenministerin die gesagt hat der
Bundeskanzler hat den Zeitpunkt der
Reise entschieden jetzt ist entscheidend
sein entscheiden die Botschaften die wir
gemeinsam festgelegt haben im
Koalitionsvertrag die Botschaften die
auch ich hier mit nach Zentralasien
gebracht habe um auch die in China
deutlich zu machen so Annalena bärburg
davon von all den Botschaften hat der
Bundeskanzler überhaupt gar nichts
gesagt und das merkt man dann auch sehr
konkret in der Politik die diese
Bundesregierung macht Herr Kollege
Trittin das was sie gerade im angemahnt
haben das geschieht eben alles nicht das
zurück verlagern das haben sie gefordert
das unabhängig machen nein man geht
tiefer in eine Abhängigkeit von China
rein und das hat keine Entscheidung so
deutlich gemacht wie die Entscheidung
dass man kosko einen Beteiligung wenn
auch eine Minderheitsbeteiligung aber
eine Beteiligung an kritischer
Infrastruktur im Hamburger Hafen
zugelassen hat und Frau stark Watzinger
die bundesforschungsminister hat das
kritisiert und hat gesagt das darf man
nicht machen und um mit nuripur von den
Grünen hat gesagt das darf man nicht
machen und dennoch hat der Bundeskanzler
das gemacht und meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren das zeigt am Ende das
ist genauso wie bei den
Panzerlieferungen nach in die Ukraine
die nicht stattfinden am Ende spielen
Grüne und FDP in der Außenpolitik der
Musik Deutschland keine Rolle der
Bundeskanzler entscheidet das alleine
und er macht verkehrte Außenpolitik an
dieser Stelle liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen
und da muss ich weil ich die geschätzte
Kollege Jensen hier auch sehe die ja
gemeinsam mit der FDP-Fraktion in der
letzten Legislaturperiode Graf lambsdorf
wird das auch entsinnen Wert darauf
gelegt hat dass wir gegenüber China eine
klare Politik machen und sogar gefordert
hat dass der EU China Gipfel abgesagt
wird so sind sie aufgedreht das hat ihr
Parteivorsitz der Christian Lindner
gefragt und haben sie in der
Bundesregierung jeden Anspruch
aufgegeben mit einem kabinettposten
internationale Politik zu machen und da
sieht man jetzt eben auch ganz praktisch
von ihrem Anspruch eine deutlicher
China-Politik zu machen die dieser die
diese Kritik
rüberbringt und in deutsche Politik
übersetzt ist nichts übrig geblieben und
deswegen es gibt jeden Anlass eine
kohärente deutsche China Politik zu
formulieren die deutlich macht das ist
ein systemischer Rivale dem wir uns
gemeinsam mit unseren europäischen
Partnern entgegenstellen vielen Dank
Johann badepfuhl einer der
schäfertretenden Vorsitzenden der
cdu/csu-fraktion im Deutschen Bundestag
und es folgt einer der stellvertretenden
Vorsitzenden der SPD-Fraktion im
Deutschen Bundestag nämlich in Dagmar
Schmidt und wir sind immer noch in der
Aktuellen Stunde zur Lage in China
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ich wünschte es
gäbe heute ein schöneren Grund um über
China zu reden aber es ist gut dass wir
das tun um unsere Solidarität mit den
Protestierenden und unser Mitgefühl mit
den vielen Menschen die unter den
radikalen Maßnahmen leiden zum Ausdruck
zu bringen am vergangenen Wochenende
haben so viele Menschen in China
protestiert wie seit 1989 nicht mehr sie
protestieren gegen eine
corona-politik die keine Exit-Strategie
hat die die Menschen einsperrt überwacht
drangsaliert und immer öfter zu Elend
und Tod führt weil die Grundversorgung
mit Nahrung weil medizinische Hilfe und
persönlicher Kontakt fehlen weil Arbeit
und Einkommen nicht mehr gesichert sind
bei Menschen in ihren Fabriken Wohnungen
oder Universitäten festsetzen weil
Schulen geschlossen Kinder von ihren
Eltern getrennt werden und weil der
versperrte Weg zum Krankenhaus oder der
versperrte Weg der Feuerwehr kostet wir
fühlen mit Ihnen und stehen an ihrer
Seite
schon früh zu Beginn der corona-pandemie
wurde die Systemfrage gestellt und
diskutiert kann eine Demokratie oder
kann eine Autokratie besser mit einer
solchen Pandemie umgehen in China wurden
nachdem das Virus nicht mehr zu leugnen
war rigorosem Maßnahmen ergriffen selbst
die WHO attestierte seinerzeit dass
diese eindämmungsmaßnahmen in China
effektiv sein und im Lande erzählte man
wie erfolgreich die eigene Strategie im
Vergleich zu den im besten sei wo man im
Chaos versinke und gleichzeitig
verschärfte die Regierung Kontrollen und
Überwachung und an der
überlegenheitsstrategie der nullkovic
und der
gegenheitsüberlegenheitserzählung der
nullkovic-strategie wurde auch noch
festgehalten als man feststellen musste
dass das Virus mutiert und die
ansteckendere ommikon Variante neue
Herausforderungen hat als man
feststellen musste dass die eigenen
Impfstoffe schlechter vor schweren
Krankheitsverläufen schützen als die
mRNA Impfstoffe und dass die
Priorisierung der Impfkampagne die
unserer Stadt ältere adressierte falsch
und die impflücke zu groß ist und das
Gesundheitssystem vor Überlastung zu
schützen man hat den Ausstieg aus der
nullkovic-strategie verpasst weil sie
eben längst keine Strategie mehr war
sondern ein Dogma
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Deutschland hat eines der besten
Gesundheitssysteme der Welt und dennoch
haben auch wir erlebt wie schwierig die
pandemische Situation zu beherrschen ist
dass auch wir nicht immer wissen konnten
was genau geschehen wird und was der
beste Umgang mit der Pandemie ist aber
wir haben das Privileg in einer
Demokratie zu leben alle können offen
ihre Meinung sagen können gegen das
Impfen protestieren und auch die Straße
gehen all das hält eine funktionierende
Demokratie aus doch gleichzeitig
diskutieren wir Probleme
wissensorientiert und lösen Sie wir
diskutieren wegen ab korrigieren Fehler
und passen unsere Politik an wenn es
neue Erkenntnisse oder sich verändernde
lagen gibt seines Mutationen
Fortschritte beim Impfen und neue
Medikamente wir waren und sind weiß Gott
nicht immer einer Meinung aber
Wissenschaft und Politik haben
argumentiert diskutiert Studien gewälzt
gute Kompromisse gefunden und damit
offen und nachvollziehbar gehandelt wir
haben zusammengehalten
darauf können wir stolz sein
noch ist die Pandemie nicht
vorbei stehen nach wie vor vor
schwierigen Entscheidungen aber während
wir uns hierzulande auf den Weg in die
Normalität machen steht China noch vor
grundsätzlichen Entscheidungen China
steckt in einem Dilemma drei Jahre
nullkovic-strategie haben eine relativ
geringe Zahl von Todesfällen und
Infektionen gebracht aber zu hohen
Kosten und ein Weg hin zur Normalität
ist noch nicht in Sicht China selbst hat
21 Punkteplan vorgestellt mit dem die
corona-politik angepasst werden soll und
vieles darin wie die neue impfstrategie
ist richtig es ist im Kern aber eine
Abkehr von der nullkovic-strategie und
die Umsetzung daher offen und noch
fragwürdig viele hatten aber in China
gehofft dass ich nach dem Parteitag
etwas ändert weiterhin verfolgen die
Behörden jedoch ihre Hosen Maßnahmen und
ein Ende ist immer noch nicht in Sicht
das führt in einem ohnehin pandemieten
Volk zu zusätzliche Verunsicherung und
gut und die
überlegenheitserzählung der chinesischen
nullkovic-strategie funktioniert nicht
mehr wir können ermessen wie
unerträglich die Situation für viele
Menschen in China sein muss so
unerträglich dass sie trotz der Gefahren
protestieren und damit ihre Freiheit
ihre Gesundheit und ihr Leben riskieren
diese Ereignisse in China dürfen uns
nicht unberührt lassen wir hoffen auf
kluge Entscheidungen auf einen
friedlichen Umgang mit dem friedlichen
Protest und einen Weg zu mehr Freiheit
für die Menschen in China
Detmar Schmidt war das aus der
SPD-Fraktion wo sie eine der
stellvertretenden Fraktionsvorsitzenden
ist in der Debatte nicht nur über die
Lage in China sondern auch zur deutschen
China Politik sie wissen dass an einer
China Strategie gearbeitet wird in der
Bundesregierung und in dieser Debatte
jetzt Jürgen braun
menschenrechtspolitischer Sprecher der
Reifen die Fraktion völlig gesunde
Bürger werden unter anderem drakonischer
Strafmaßnahmen eingeschüchtert oder den
Beifall der Staatsmedien werden
Wasserwerfer gegen friedliche
Demonstranten eingesetzt bei
Demonstrationsteilnehmer werden
Hausdurchsuchungen vorgenommen Handys
beschlagnahmt im Internet Zensur und
Einschränkungen der Meinungsfreiheit die
Menschenrechtslage so verheerend dass
sich die UNO einschaltet
das ist nicht nur die gegenwärtige Lage
in der Volksrepublik China das war bis
letztes Jahr auch Teil der Lage in
Deutschland
die Bundesregierungen haben sich selbst
so verhalten wie es die Kommunistische
Partei Chinas nach wie vor tut
auch hier bei uns Besuch von Verwandten
in einem anderen Bundesland verboten
allein auf einer Parkbank ein Buch lesen
verboten Schlittenfahren mit der Familie
in der frischen an der frischen Luft
verboten den uns janten gefördert sie
beklagen sich jetzt zu Recht über Zensur
in China aber was haben sie selbst bis
vor kurzem gefördert im Staatsfernsehen
tagtäglich Beschallung mit irrelevanten
zahlen die nur ein Ziel hatten die
Verbreitung von Angst wie beim televisor
aus Orwells 1984 zeitgleich wurden
Kritiker dieser Umstände diffamiert und
bekämpft freiheitsliebende Spaziergänger
als aluhüte und Rechtsextremisten
beschimpft und das Restaurants schwimmen
wir dann und Fitnessstudios verbannt mit
anderen von Beugehaft und
Rentenkürzungen ein
SPD-Oberbürgermeister bei Stuttgart
erlaubte gar Schusswaffen gegen
Spaziergänger einzusetzen
Polizeigewalt in Deutschland so massiv
wie seit über 30 Jahren seit dem Ende
des SED-Regimes nicht mehr so massiv
dass sich der UNO Sonderberichterstatter
für Folter einschaltete
Polizeigewalt wie wir sie zurecht in
China beklagen auch hier bei uns und
nahezu nahezu alle von ihnen haben
mitgemacht Herr Trittin sie haben die
Impfpflicht für alle gefordert jetzt
können Sie viele über Freiheit in China
reden Herr Lauterbach ist ja
passenderweise gar nicht da
wogegen sich jetzt mutige Chinesen
wenden wurde hier jahrelang praktiziert
die totalitäre Zero Kurve Petition die
wurde von den führenden Figuren des
Mainstreams unterzeichnet
sirup-hüpferin Luisa Neubauer die
staatsfinanz der staatsfinanzierte Georg
Reste sogar der vom Stasi Mann zum
Berliner Staatssekretär aufgestiegene
andere Holm war mit von der Partie auch
Christian Drosten hat in der
Fachzeitschrift Talente hören sie zu
herrnsdorf die Wahrheit wollen sie nicht
hören das weiß ich ist mir klar ja in
der Präsident sind zum
bedingungslosen ich bitte zum immer der
Aktuellen Stunde und der
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach erst das
ist chinesische Null covet-ideologie in
reihenform jetzt will der politisch
mediale Komplex all das plötzlich
vergessen machen angesichts der
brutalunterdrückten Proteste in China an
diesem Wochenende lügen sich deutsche
Staatsmedien mal wieder im Kopf und
Kragen der Tagesschau heißt es ich
zitiere große Impfkampagnen gibt es in
diesem Land mit 1,4 Milliarden
Einwohnern nicht stattdessen leben die
Menschen in China seit knapp drei Jahren
mit immer wiederkehrenden lockdowns
Massentests ausgangs- und
reisebeschränkung Zitat Ende dabei hat
die Volksrepublik China eine Impfquote
von
89%. eine der höchsten der Welt aber
keine noch zu hohe Impfquote hat zum
Einknicken der deutschen Regierung in
Sachen Null Covic geführt nein es waren
hartnäckige Bürgerproteste und
Bürgerproteste allein den wir das zu
verdanken haben die chinesische
Strategie
die chinesische Strategie der
Einschüchterung und Einsperrung die hier
und heute zu Recht einhellig verurteilt
wird war deutsche staatson und sie wäre
staatsresaison geblieben wenn nicht die
wahre Zivilgesellschaft aufgestanden
wird wäre über ganz Deutschland verteilt
friedliche Spaziergänge um dieser
skandalösenpolitik endlich Einhalt zu
gebieten
zur Verteidigung der jetzigen Regierung
ist zu sagen dass sie auch nur
weitergeführt hat was schon unter der
Merkel Regierung begonnen hatte in den
Expertenrat des Innenministeriums berief
sie einen Mann der nicht nur erklärter
Fan von Mao Zedong ist sondern auch Geld
von der Kommunistischen Partei Chinas
bekam der linguistel war der Verfasser
des propagandistischen angstpapiers
unter dem verräterischen Titel von Wuhan
lernen ausgerechnet wo Hahn wo das neue
Corona-Virus entstanden ist ich sage
Ihnen was man von wohan lernen kann wie
man ein Virus gentechnisch so
manipuliert das ist hochvirulent wird
und man damit eine weltweite Massenpanik
auslösen kann sie wollten auch noch das
chinesische Gesellschaftsmodell
imitieren aber der deutsche Sonderweg
gelangt Gott sei Dank zu einem Ende wenn
jetzt noch die maskenpflicht komplett
fällt dann haben wir endlich unsere
Freiheit wieder und das wünsche ich auch
den mutigen Menschen in China
Jürgen braun aus der afd-fraktion mit
seiner Sicht auf die Dinge in einer
Debatte des Deutschen Bundestages zur
Lage in China und zur deutschen China
Politik mehr dazu jetzt von Alexander
Graf Lambsdorff aus der FDP-Fraktion da
ist der stellvertretender Vorsitzender
hier war so leicht der schwefelduft ich
musste den vertreiben
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
wir alle sehen die Bilder aus China
Demonstranten mit weißen Blättern wir
sehen die Ausbrüche aus den
abgeriegelten Wohnviertel wir hören und
das ist wirklich eine neue Qualität auch
die politischen Forderungen der
Demonstranten und Demonstranten nun da
ist es so dass in der China Daily dem
Blatt der Kommunistischen Partei
kürzlich zu lesen war und ich zitiere
die Unannehmlichkeiten der Bevölkerung
im Kampf gegen das Virus sollten im
Kontext eines größeren Bildes betrachtet
werden meine Damen und Herren lassen Sie
mich kurz dieses größere Bild skizzieren
lassen Sie uns gemeinsam betrachten
wovon China Daily spricht nach dem
Schulterschluss mit Putin die Ukraine
angegriffen Chinas Droge werden
gegenüber Taiwan waren nie so offensiv
wie in diesem Jahr im Iran warfen
Tausende von Frauen
Demonstrationen das gesamte Land wo
stehen wir also heute im November
Psalm 22 im Kontext eines größeren
Bildes Putin sieht sich schweren
innenpolitischen Verwerfungen gegenüber
einer massiven internationalen Isolation
und eine militäre strategischen
Fehlschlag das mularegime im Iran
bekämpft den Aufstand an der breiten
iranischen Öffentlichkeit der sich an
den Brutalität des Regimes entzündet hat
und chising Ping erntet die Früchte
seiner corona-politik das Volk hat nach
Jahren eine exzessiven repressiven Zero
kovage Strategie zurückgeschlagen und
verbindet dies mit politischen
Forderungen wer wollte ihnen das
verdenken totale
lockdowns über mehr als zwei Monate
eingesperrte Menschen ohne genug zu
essen kranke Kinder die von ihren Eltern
getrennt wurden ganze Wohnviertel die
abgesperrt wurden staatliche
desinfektionskampagnen in Abertausenden
von Privatwohnungen Zahl und Intensität
der staatlichen Willkür Eingriffe in
China sind genauso erschreckend wie die
hartnäckige Steigerung der macht aber in
Peking endlich westliche Impfstoffe ins
Land zu lassen diese aber braucht es
wenn das Land über die nächsten Monate
zu einem Anschein von Normalität
zurückkehren will stattdessen beharrt
die Führung der Kommunistischen Partei
auf sinowack eine minderwertigen
Impfstoff für den die Impfquote
vollkommen unerheblich ist meine Damen
und Herren
noch einmal der Kontext eines größeren
Bildes am Ende dieses Jahres zeigt sich
über deutlich das nationalistische
islamistische und kommunistische
Diktaturen scheitern sie scheitern an
ihrem Anspruch ihren Bürgerinnen und
Bürgern ein besseres Leben in Freiheit
Wohlstand und würde zu garantieren als
wir von Ihnen so oft geschmähte und
angeblich verachtete Westen aber
Verhalten der Menschen in exakt diesen
Ländern in diesen Diktaturen sieht man
wie verlogen die Politik der macht aber
in Wahrheit ist die Demonstranten wollen
ihren Landsleuten nicht etwa eine
westliche Lebensweise auch zwingen es
hat mit West und Ost Nord und Süd
überhaupt nichts zu tun nein was wir im
Kontext des größeren Bildes sehen
das ist die ureigene Sehnsucht des
Menschen nach einem Leben in Freiheit
und Würde und das ist eine Sehnsucht die
auch die Menschen in China haben frei
reisen frei Glauben frei lieben
paradoxerweise sind die universellen
Menschenrechte die ja gerade deswegen so
erfolgreich so wirkmächtig weil sie in
höchstem Maße individuell sind aber es
zählen auch dazu frei publizieren frei
demonstrieren und frei wählen in der
Geschichte der Menschheit gibt es keinen
Gesellschaftsmodell dass die
unverletzbarkeit der menschlichen Würde
in so hohem Maß gewährleistet wie die
freiheitliche Demokratie und der
vielleicht wichtigste Unterschied
zwischen den Liberalen und den
illiberalen Gesellschaften besteht darin
das erste Kritik zulassen und letztere
sie mit allen Mitteln zu unterdrücken
suchen das Jahr 2022 hat uns diesen
Unterschied auf mannigfaltige Weise
gezeigt eben zuletzt in China und viele
die in Russland im Iran oder auch in
China auf Missstände Hinweisen riskieren
damit lange Haftstrafen
umerziehungslage oder unterschreiben
sogar ihr Todesurteil ihr Mut meine
Damen und Herren ihr Mut ist uns
Beispiel wir verneigen uns vor Ihnen wir
verneigen uns vor den Menschen die sich
für Freiheit Menschenrechte Demokratie
und Rechtsstaat einsetzen im Iran in
Russland und jetzt auch in China von
herzlichen Dank
Alex
Folgen seven
Sprecherin für internationale Politik in
der Linksfraktion und es geht weiter um
China und die deutsche China Politik
frau Präsidentin meine Damen und Herren
gegen repressive covid-maßnahmen zu
demonstrieren ist ein Menschenrecht
unabhängig davon ob es in China Kanada
Deutschland oder anderswo in der Welt
ausgeübt wird
wer aber die wer aber die Universalität
der Menschenrechte verteidigt der darf
nicht in unterschiedlichen Ländern
völlig andere Maßstäbe gelten lassen und
für ihr herangehen gilt in besonderem
Maße der Satz aus der Bergpredigt ich
zitiere warum siehst du den Splitter im
Auge deines Bruders aber dem Balken in
deinem Auge bemerkst du nicht Matthäus 7
Absatz Teil Ende denn eines geht nicht
meine Damen und Herren hier in
Deutschland noch lockdowns
Ausgangssperren Schulschließungen
impfpflichten zu rufen und die Proteste
dagegen
unisono als rechts oder covidioten oder
als schnurler zu denunzieren und alle
diejenigen die in China gegen die
Maßnahmen der zero-
als Freiheitskämpfer zu erheben
und ich hoffe dass Ihnen dass irgendwann
irgendwann auffallen wird denn sie haben
bereits jetzt international mit ihren
doppelten Standards was die
Glaubwürdigkeit der deutschen Politik
insgesamt angeht schweren Schaden
angerichtet vom wirtschaftlichen Abstieg
begleitet für den allein diese
Bundesregierung die Verantwortung trägt
ist Deutschland dabei in einem ganz
anderen Bereich eine Spitzenposition zur
erobern im Bereich der Moral oder
genauer gesagt im Bereich der
Doppelmoral und ich kann nur warnen
davor diese Doppelmoral auch in punkto
China anzulegen und ich möchte Ihnen
auch Beispiele ihrer doppelbereich geben
heute morgen im Auswärtigen Ausschuss
haben wir die Bundesregierung gefragt ob
sie den Angriff des nato-partners Türkei
auf Syrien als Völkerrechtsbruch ansieht
diese Bundesregierung hat gehandelt dass
sie die Bombardierungen der Türkei der
völkerrechtlich nicht bewerten kann es
fehlten ihr genügend Hinweise für diese
Bewertung und wissen Sie was noch dazu
kommt das Auswärtige Amt konnte am
Vormittag ja noch nicht einmal
beantworten wie die Bundesregierung den
Krieg der USA und der Koalition der
Willigen 2003 gegen den Irak
völkerrechtlich bewertet und will die
Antwort nachreichen und wir sind
gespannt ob auch hier weil es sich um
einen Nato-Partner handelt der
Bundesregierung selbst 19 Jahre nach dem
us-angriffskrieg nicht genügend Hinweise
vorliegen um eine völkerrechtliche
Bewertung vorzunehmen ich hoffe sie
warten nicht darauf dass diese
vermeintlichen Massen Vernichtungswaffen
im Irak noch irgendwie gefunden werden
damit sie uns anwirken können
international kommen Sie mit diesen
Nebelkerzen meine Damen und Herren nicht
durch wer lediglich weltmeisterlich bei
der Doppelmoral ist der verspielt jede
Glaubwürdigkeit um global für
Menschenrechte und die Anhaltung des
Völkerrechtes einzustehen und ich will
Ihnen noch ein Beispiel geben
Qatar auf der einen Seite legen sie sich
die Regenbogen
Armbändern sollte liefern sie Waffen an
dieses Land und schließen einen Deal
über die Lieferung von Flüssiggas ab auf
der einen Seite erklärt die
bundesaußenministerin Annalena Berber
man dürfe sich nie wieder abhängig
machen von einem Land das unsere Welt
Werte nicht teilt auf der andere Seite
versuchen Sie russisches Gas zu ersetzen
durch Deals mit den Diktatoren am Gold
oder sagen bei mir ist es jetzt soweit
dass sie uns weiß machen wollen dass
Katha und Saudi-Arabien unsere Werte
teilen Kollegen
dieser Politik der Doppelmoral auch
hinsichtlich China was wir dringend
brauchen ist eine vernünftige
Realpolitik die auf Diplomatie und
Ausgleich setzt anstatt auf
ideologiebetriebene Blockkonfrontation
im Dienste einer vermeintlich höheren
Moral
und ich möchte auch ihnen noch eins
sagen
hören sie auf Deutschland mit ihrem
Gewebe von systemischer Rivalität in
diese Blockkonfrontation der USA mit
China zu treiben China ist Deutschlands
wichtigster Handelspartner
zentraler Rohstofflieferant und einer
der wichtigsten
innovations- und technologiebetreiber
weltweit eine Entkoppelung von China
hätte für die Mehrheit der Bevölkerung
in Deutschland katastrophale Folgen wer
weniger Abhängigkeit fordert muss auch
ehrlich sagen
Abhängigkeit ist die Grundlage unseres
Wohlstandes weniger Abhängigkeit
bedeutet weniger Wohlstand das müssen
sie einfach ehrlich mal sagen und ihr
erster Wirtschaftskrieg ist schon ein
Bumerang den die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
hier in Deutschland teuer bezahlen wir
brauchen wahrlich nicht noch einen
zweiten der Deutschland dann voll ins
ruinieren wird vielen Dank
[Applaus]
war das aus der Linksfraktion im
Deutschen Bundestag nächster Redner Nils
Schmied der ist außenpolitischer
Sprecher der SPD-Fraktion
Frau Präsident meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren
wie tief muss man sinken liebe Kollegin
dadelen um bei einer Rede über die
chinesische corona-politik nur eine
Aussage zu treffen die bezogen auf die
corona-politik von China aus ihrem Munde
kam nämlich es zu vergleichen mit den
deutschen restriktiven Maßnahmen als wir
die Corona bekämpft haben wie tief muss
man trinken und wir erbärmlich ist es
dass sie über alles andere reden bloß
nicht über die Unterdrückung der
Menschenrechte in China wie erbärmlich
ist das
wenn du sagst ich sage Ihnen eins
das kaum jemand von ihrer Fraktion noch
anwesend war bei ihr rede und dass ihr
Applaus von Rechtsaußen bekommen haben
zeigt an auf welche rutschige schiefe
Bahn die Linkspartei in der Außenpolitik
sich inzwischen begeben hat
und ich hätte mir schon gewünscht dass
angesichts der dystopischen Bilder die
uns aus China seit Jahren erreichen Sie
ein paar Worte des Mitgefühls für die
abertausende Jahr Millionen von Menschen
gefunden hätten die seit Jahren
weggesperrt worden sind wo Säuglinge von
ihren Eltern getrennt werden wo
massenhaft infizierte interniert werden
das ist doch das was uns aus China
erreicht und das hat mit den
restriktiven Maßnahmen die in
demokratischen Gesellschaft und im Zuge
der corona-bekämpfung getroffen worden
sind nicht aber überhaupt nichts zu tun
und deshalb verwahre ich mich gegen jede
Vermischung in dieser Debatte
ich will aber auch sagen es gibt
ermutigende Bilder aus China das ist ja
auch der Anlass der Debatte Menschen die
aufstehen und sagen sie lassen sich das
nicht mehr länger bieten und Graf
Lambsdorff hat zu Recht darauf
hingewiesen der Wunsch nach Freiheit
nach persönlicher Entfaltung ist
universell
er ist nicht ein Kulturen gebunden er
darf nicht relativiert werden mit dem
Verweis auf vermeintliche asiatische
Werte chinesische Traditionen
afrikanische Werte oder was auch immer
es ist universell und das sollte uns Mut
machen auch im Falle von China die
Gesellschaft in China wird sich
weiterentwickeln ich sehe nicht erwartet
cool dass das Regime schon oft Höhen und
Füßen stünde aber die Kraft der Freiheit
wird früher oder später auch in China
sich durchsetzen und sich Bahn brechen
und die Menschen in China werden über
den Weg den sie durch ihr Leben
schreiten wollen individuell entscheiden
können und das wollen wir nach Kräften
von außen befördern und unterstützen
denn wir teilen mit diesen Chinesinnen
und Chinesen diesen Wunsch nach Freiheit
in der Bekämpfung des Coronavirus ist
die systemrivalität zwischen autoritären
und demokratischen System deutlich zu
Tage gedrehten der Streit um die beste
Lösung ist in Demokratie möglich das
Ringen um bessere Lösungen das auswärts
von nicht so erfolgreichen
Lösungsansätzen das ständige verbessern
der Politik ist bei uns im Streit im
Parlament und außerhalb des Parlamentes
auf der Straße in den Medien möglich
während es in China nicht möglich ist
und deshalb ist China ist Präsident sie
jetzt in dieser Sackgasse aus der nicht
herauskommt und ich habe die Vermutung
das ist schon lange nicht mehr nur um
den richtigen Weg der corona-bekämpfung
geht sondern letzten Endes
erleben wir gerade ein groß ein
gesellschaftliches großexperiment in
China wie lange sich eine Gesellschaft
es sich bieten lässt das ein ganzes Volk
weggesperrt wird denn China ist Politik
der letzten Jahre zieht ja auch auf eine
allgemeine Abschöpfung von der
Weltgesellschaft und des Austausches mit
anderen Gesellschaft in der Welt und
deshalb ist es auch so verständlich dass
die Chinesinnen und Chinesen sich das
nicht länger bieten lassen wir wissen
aber auch die repressionsmittel sind
groß und stark deshalb können wir nicht
draufsetzen dass mit einem Schlag
Demokratie und Freiheit sich durchsetzen
aber wir können drei Sachen aus meiner
Sicht sehr sehr deutlich machen erstens
friedliche Proteste das Recht auf freie
Meinungsäußerung auf der Straße muss
auch in China Geld
zweitens Berichterstattung über solche
Proteste muss möglich sein für
Journalistin aus dem In- und Ausland es
darf nicht sein dass Journalisten
weggesperrt werden festgenommen werden
ja misshandelt werden und drittens bei
aller systemrivalität und allen
Wettbewerb den wir in Wirtschaft und
technologie-austragen es gibt auch ein
Angebot zur Kooperation es gibt
Impfstoffe
westlicher Provenienz die
selbstverständlich auch der chinesischen
Regierung angeboten werden wir sind
bereit Europa ist bereit Impfstoffe zu
teilen mit Chinesen und Chinesen damit
sie einen besseren Impfschutz erreichen
können auch dieses Angebot steht und das
sollten wir auch deutlich aussprechen an
die Menschen in China die diese Hilfe im
Kampf gegen das Coronavirus dringend
brauchen könnten herzlichen Dank
war das außenpolitischer Sprecher der
SPD-Fraktion und es geht hier nach wie
vor um die Proteste in China um die
deutsche China-Politik die noch nicht so
ganz in den Vordergrund der Aussprache
gerückt ist der nächste Redner ist
Nicolas cipelius aus der Unionsfraktion
des Mitglied im Ausschuss für
wirtschaftliche Zusammenarbeit und
Entwicklung meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren
protestkind viele Formen still laut
einsam oder in Massen der Kollege kritis
hat gerade schon angesprochen in China
ist es derzeit ein weißes Blatt Papier
es sind aber auch Blumensträuße oder
eine Tierrasse die bei richtiger
Aussprache auch eine gewisse Kritik an
der Parteiführung ausdrücken kann und
die Bilder die wir aus China erhalten
die haben Gründe
langfristige Gründe nämlich die Zero
cobbit-politik welche die kommunistische
Parteien nun seit fast drei Jahren
rigoros durchsetzt und kurzfristige
Gründe in dem Fall der Lockdown in
chinchang infolgedessen 10 Personen zu
Tode gekommen waren zu Tode gekommen
weil sie das Gebäude nicht verlassen
konnten dass sie da eingesperrt waren
meine Damen und Herren auch schon
angesprochen aber genauso richtig vom
Herrn Kollegen Schmied die Proteste
haben ihren Ursprung in einem ureigenen
Streben des Menschen und zwar in dem
Streben nach Freiheit
was ist aber an diesem Protesten anders
landesweite Proteste zum gleichen Thema
sind in China extrem selten wir müssen
diesbezüglich genauer hinsehen denn hier
demonstriert ein Querschnitt der
Bevölkerung Alt und Jung intellektuelle
Arbeiter Landwirte Studenten
handchinesen und andere Ethnien und
daraus gilt es aus die richtigen
Schlüsse zu ziehen die Proteste zeigen
die Unzufriedenheit der Bürger mit dem
Umgang der Zero Corvette Politik mit der
Pandemie und
die Politik sollte ursprünglich
Überlegenheit des eigenen Systems
gegenüber dem Westen zeigen und die
angeblich anfänglichen Erfolge haben
sich inzwischen aber zerschlagen und wir
sehen auch daran sehr genau
Systeme sind eben keine Antwort auf die
großen Herausforderungen unserer Zeit
hier kommen wir aber der Titel sagte
schon zur deutschen China-Politik und da
kann es nicht ganz ohne Kritik bleiben
bislang zu den zu den Geschehnissen vor
China bleiben die Worte der
Außenministerin fehlend bislang ist sie
absolut stumm obwohl wir wissen dass zum
Beispiel laut Artikel 35 der chinesische
Verfassung die Rede und
Versammlungsfreiheit geschützt ist und
wir erwarten von unserer Seite dass das
Außenministerium und die Außenministerin
da eine klare Botschaft übersendet
[Applaus]
und so kommen wir auch zu China-Politik
und auf die china-strategie zu sprechen
denn die China-Politik der
Bundesregierung die steht für das
Handeln der Ampelkoalition in
vergangenen Jahr sinnbildlich entgegen
der ersten Ankündigung hängt sie dem
Zeitplan hinterher sie bleibt weit
hinter den Erwartungen zurück und eine
Einigkeit ist überhaupt nicht
ersichtlich viel schlimmer noch der
Streit bezüglich der China Strategie und
der China Politik wird in der Koalition
ganz offen auf offener Bühne ausgetragen
und man fragt sich dann schon wenn die
Außenministerin einerseits einen Werte
geleiteten Ansatz propagiert
wo der enden soll denn dieser Wert werde
geleitet der Ansatz der bröckelt oder
bröckelt nicht auf internationaler Bühne
nein der zerbröckelt am Widerstand 400
Meter von hier entfernt im Bundeskanzler
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
und wir beschäftigen uns als
Unionsfraktion intensiv mit der China
Politik der Bundesregierung aus meinem
Büro stammen mehrere schriftliche
Anfragen wir haben eine kleine Anfrage
zur china-strategie der Bundesregierung
gestellt mit 57 konkreten Fragen 57
konkrete Fragen unter anderem z.B zu den
Leitlinien der Bundesregierung der Inno
Pazifik Strategie aus dem Jahr 2021 und
wie die konkreten die China Strategie
eingearbeitet wird ein Drittel ein
Drittel dieser Frage wurde mit einer
standardisierten Antwort beantwortet und
wenn zeitgleich dich hier im
Regierungsviertel Journalisten über den
ersten Entwurf der China Strategie
verfügen dann kann man an dieser Stelle
nur sagen die nicht Beantwortung unserer
Kleinen Anfrage während gleichzeitig aus
dem Außenministerium an Journalisten
durchgesteckt wird das ist eine Form der
Missachtung des Parlaments was überhaupt
nicht geht meine Damen und Herren
das stimmt und
apropos Entwurf China Strategie der
Bundesregierung in diesem kommt das Wort
Diaspora zum Beispiel kein einziges Mal
vor wenn wir allerdings wissen welche
Bedeutung Auslands Chinesen für die
chinesische Führung haben ist dieser
blinde Fleck in der Ausarbeitung des
Außenministeriums gerade zu fatal und
das zieht sich durch das zieht sich
durch die Außenministerin will nach
außen Härte projizieren und gleichzeitig
trifft sich der Bundeskanzler unter vier
Augen in China springen und spricht
danach von Verlässlichkeit und Vertrauen
und da Liebe Koalition China Politik
müssen sie sich immer wieder darüber
planen werden was das auch für ein
Zeichen nach außen gibt der renommierte
französische China-Experte Francois Gott
guten Morgen weil das Statement des
Bundeskanzlers zu Verlässlichkeit und
Vertrauen pures Entsetzen und ich komme
zum Schluss wir müssen an dieser Stelle
bemerken
die
kompetenzbezüglich der Außenpolitik die
liegt bei mit Sicherheit nicht im
Außenministerium die liegt bei
Bundeskanzler Scholz und bei seinem
wichtigsten beraten Herrn blödner von
dem es heißt dass er die Außenpolitik
deutlicher gestalten wird als die
außenministerinisterin in dieser
Legislatur jemals können wird herzlichen
Dank
Nicolas sipelius war das und ich kann
nur sagen kaum habe ich es reklamiert
gehabt dass hier die China Strategie der
Bundesregierung noch nicht im
Mittelpunkt steht wird sie im Mittel
oder steht sie im Mittelpunkt der
Redebeitrags von Nicolas cipelius und
wir können mal ein bisschen mutmaßen das
ist eine direkte Erwiderung zu dem einen
und anderen Punkt jetzt geben wird von
Tobias Lindner der ist Staatsminister
bei der Bundesministerin des auswärtigen
liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren
der tragische Tod von zehn Menschen bei
einem Wohnhausbrand in der
nordwestchinesischen Stadt rumschied
mutmaßlich starben weil zur besseren
kobit-kontrolle wichtige Notausgänge
verflossen waren hat eine Welle von
Protestkundgebungen in China ausgelöst
die Unzufriedenheit mit einem Politik
der chinesischen Führung ist so groß
dass viele Menschen bereit sind enorm
Risiken auf sich zu nehmen um ihre
Meinung öffentlich zu äußern das zeigen
die friedlichen Proteste in Peking in
Shanghai in Wuhan und in vielen anderen
chinesischen Städten seit dem
vergangenen Wochenende die Menschen in
China darunter viele junge Frauen machen
mit ihren Protesten von ihrem
Menschenrecht auf freie
Meinungsäußerungen Gebrauch einem recht
dass wir in freien Gesellschaft und
wieder unsringen oft als
selbstverständlich erachten und zudem
sich China in seiner Verfassung es ist
bereits erwähnt worden ebenfalls
verpflichtet hat die Ereignisse
dass sie immer willkürlich aber
Durchsetzung der sogenannten
null-kovic-politik nicht mehr von der
Bevölkerung akzeptiert wird und sie
zeigen auch meine Damen und Herren das
ist den Menschen in China eben nicht
egal ist was in shingyang passiert die
Solidarisierung zwischen Chinesinnen und
Chinesen und in den Yang unterdrückten
olguren hat sich damit zum ersten Mal
innerhalb Chinas öffentlich und für
jeden sichtbar manifestiert liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen ganz besonders
sticht mir dabei ins Auge dass die
Forderungen nach Lockerung der Politik
vielfach auch mit Forderungen nach
politischen Wandel verbunden werden wir
sehen einmal mehr dass es eben nicht
möglich ist in einer Gesellschaft jede
abweichende Meinung dauerhaft zu
unterdrücken und liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen da Mut derjenigen Menschen in
China die es wagen sich der
allgegenwärtigen Überwachung
Unterdrückung und
Einschüchterungsversuchen durch
staatlichen Stellen offen entgegen zu
dieser Mut liebe Kolleginnen Kollegen
verdient unseren Respekt und unsere
Hochachtung
die leider zu erwarten war hat die
chinesische Führung mit repressiven
Maßnahmen mit noch weiliger Ausweitung
der Internetzensur und mit massiver
Einschüchterung der Bevölkerung auf
diese Proteste reagiert wir appellieren
daher an die chinesische Regierung den
Wunsch und das rechte eigenen Regierung
nach freier Meinungsäußerung zu achten
und sich mit ihren berechtigten Anliegen
auseinanderzusetzen wir appellieren
ferner an die chinesische Regierung mehr
zu tun um die Freiheit der Presse zu
schützen die kurzzeitiger Inhaftierung
und Misshandlung eines Journalisten der
BBC im Zusammenhang mit seiner
berichtsausstattung zu den Protesten in
Shanghai sendet ein
besorgniserregendes Zeichen in alle Welt
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen natürlich
hoffen wir dass die chinesische
Regierung auf die Anliegen der
Protestierenden eingehen wird wir sehen
erste Zeichen für gewisse sehr
vorsichtige Schritte in eine richtige
Richtung bei der Anwendung der
nuk-politik so wurden beispielsweise
bestehende Bezirksleiter lockdowns in
Kanton aufgehoben es soll dort keine
weiteren Massentests mehr geben aber
lassen Sie mich klar betonen es bleibt
abzuwarten ob dies von Dauer sein wird
die chinesische Regierung steht
angesichts neuer Varianten die anstecken
das sind als sie bisherigen und stark
zunehmender Fallzahlen vor einem Dilemma
es fällt er immer schwerer ihre
gesundheitspolitischen Maßnahmen und die
Belange ihre Bevölkerung und der
Wirtschaft in einen vernünftigen
Ausgleich zu bringen
und in diesem Kontext hat unter von
Bundeskanzler Scholz gemacht das Angebot
zur Zusammenarbeit bei mrna-impfungen in
China eine herausragende Bedeutung die
Bundesregierung bekennt sich zu diesem
Angebot und wir hoffen dass China
zuzügig auf unsere Vorschläge auch
eingehen wird meine sehr geehrten Damen
und Herren
bereits angesprochen worden sie wissen
die Bundesregierung arbeitet und der
darf Federführung des Auswärtigen Amtes
derzeit an einer umfassenden Strategie
zum zukünftigen Umgang mit China wir
wollen eine enger koordinierte mehr an
unseren und europäischen Werten und
Interessen
ausgerichtete China-Politik diese Werte
und Interessen wollen wir effektiver als
bisher verteidigen und wir müssen daher
unsere einzeitigen Abhängigkeiten von
China reduzieren und somit auch weniger
verwundbar werden deswegen wollen wir
konkret unsere
außenwirtschaftsförderungsinstrumente
auch als Anreiz für Firmen einsetzen um
dort Diversifikation voranzutreiben wir
schauen auch sehr genau hin bei
ausländischen Investitionen hier in
Deutschland lassen sie mit es mich klar
sagen Deutschland ist eine offene
Marktwirtschaft die Investition wünscht
und fördert
aber diese dürfen nicht unsere
öffentliche Ordnung und Sicherheit
gefährden und wir haben von dem
Hintergrund des russischen
angriffskriegs aus der Ukraine bitter
lernen müssen welche Folgen einseitige
Abhängigkeiten für unsere
Volkswirtschaft haben können meine Damen
und Herren wir werden unsere Lehren
daraus ziehen und wir werden diesen
Fehler kein zweites Mal mehr begehen
und gleichzeitig wollen wir uns nicht
von China entkoppeln und Dialog und
Zusammenarbeit möglich sind wollen wir
diese fortsetzen sei es in Politik und
Wirtschaft das heißt in Wissenschaft und
Kultur die Europäische Union definiert
ihre Beziehungen zu China in allen
Dreiklang Partner
Konkurrent
systemischer Rivale und wir müssen
leider feststellen dass dieses chemische
Rivalität aktuell immer mehr Raum
einnimmt dass sie zum dominierenden
Faktor wird und von diesem Hintergrund
müssen wir dort wo Partnerschaft richtig
und wichtig ist dann Partnerschaft auch
entsprechend denken wir sehen aktuell
das ist kein monolithisches China gibt
wie es uns chinesische Staatsmedien
glauben machen wollen der tun deshalb in
unserer Strategie gut daran auch
weiterhin den Austausch mit chinesischen
Partnerinnen und Partnern zu suchen
und lassen Sie mich betonen wir müssen
uns mit dem China auseinandersetzen wie
wir es tatsächlich vorfinden nicht wie
wir es uns wünschen oder wie wäre es
gerne hätten und um den Bundeskanzler zu
zitieren in China sich ändert dann muss
ich auch unser Umgang mit China ändern
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
klar ist wir wollen trotz aller
Differenzen auch dort wo wir China
brauchen in Zukunft zusammenarbeiten
dabei geht es nicht nur wirtschaftliche
Fragen dabei geht es um globale fragen
wie die Klimakrise wie Fragen von
Frieden und Sicherheit wie dem Schutz
von natürlichen Lebensgrundlagen der
Nahrungsmittelsicherheit oder globalen
Gesundheitsfragen diese Herausforderung
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen werden
wir nicht ohne das bevölkerungsreichste
Land der Erde als verantwortungsvollen
Partner bewältigen können und hier
möchte ich auch noch einmal
das Ergebnis der Kopf 27 in Erinnerung
rufen es ist uns dort gelungen eine
Einigung zum schweren Thema los und
damage zu erreichen eine Einigung die
auch und gerade China als sie mit
Abstand größten Emittenten von CO2
verpflichtet für die Bewältigung von
Klimaschäden aufzukommen diese Treffen
auf die Ärmsten und damit
verletzlichsten Länder am stärksten
deshalb ist es wichtig dass die größten
Verursacher auch in der Verantwortung
stehen die Folgen zu bekämpfen
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen
Zusammenarbeit mit China somit weiter
wichtig aber lassen Sie mich in aller
Deutlichkeit sagen
wir wollen eine Zusammenarbeit nach den
Spielregeln und den Grundsätzen der
internationalen
regelbasierten Ordnung im Einklang mit
unseren Interessen und unseren Werten
und es entspricht unseren Werten das
Kritik an der Regierung und das Recht
auf freie Meinungsäußerung möglich sein
müssen
und deshalb stehen wir heute
deshalb stehen wir heute solidarisch an
der Seite aller Menschen die ihre
elementaren Grundrechte auch und gerade
auf freie Meinungsäußerung wahrnehmen
wollen in China und weltweit danke Ihnen
wir werden unsere Lehren ziehen was
Abhängigkeit von anderen Staaten angeht
wir wollen uns aber auch von China nicht
komplett entkoppeln sagt Tobias Lindner
Staatsminister bei der Bundesministerin
des auswärtigen in dieser Debatte über
die Lage in China aber auch über die
deutsche China Politik dazu jetzt
güdingensen stellvertretende Vorsitzende
der FDP-Fraktion
herzlichen Dank Frau Präsidentin liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen alle Menschen
sind frei und gleich an Würde und
Rechten geboren das ist der erste Satz
des ersten Artikels der Allgemeinen
Erklärung der Menschenrechte und jedes
Wort dieses Satzes ist elementar aber
steckt ein ganz besonderes Wort da drin
das besonders Autokraten in der Welt
riesige Angst macht
alle Menschen sind frei geboren egal ob
Russinnen Russen US-Amerikanerinnen
belarussinnen Iranerin oder eben
Chinesen alle Menschen tragen diesen
Wunsch nach Freiheit nach
Selbstbestimmung in sich es gibt keine
chinesischen Menschenrechte Chinesen
wollen nicht weniger frei oder weniger
selbstbestimmt sein es ist die
kommunistische Partei China die will
dass die Menschen in China unfrei und
weniger selbstbestimmt leben
auf der ganzen Welt nutzen Autokraten
gewissermaßen wie die Kommunistische
Partei Chinas gerade beobachten ein ganz
bestimmtes narrativ um ihr
unterdrückerisches Regime immer wieder
zurechtfertigen unsere Kultur ist eine
andere sagen sie Menschenrechte sein ein
westliches Konstrukt diese Proteste
übrigens genau wie die Proteste auch in
Iran die entlarven aber diese Erzählung
mehr denn je als große als mutwillige
als menschenverachtende Lüge meine Damen
und Herren Menschenrechte sind kein
westliches Konstrukt Menschenrechte sind
ein menschliches Konstrukt
die Kommunistische Partei Chinas hat die
chinesische Zivilgesellschaft
systematisch zerstört aber die
bürgerliche Haltung in jedem einzelnen
Chinesen in jeder einzelnen Chinesin an
die kommt die Kommunistische Partei
nicht heran auch wenn das mit einem
immer größer werdenden totalitären
überwachungsstark Staat immer weiter
versucht wird liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen das was wir in den letzten
Tagen in China sehen das sind aus meiner
Wahrnehmung nicht unbedingt nur die
Proteste gegen die drakonische zeroco
wird Politik von Präsident Chi es geht
da um mehr denn die Menschen rufen
nieder mit dem pingen sie rufen nieder
mit der Kommunistischen Partei sie
fordern Transparenz sie riskieren dafür
ihre Freiheit denn in China erfasst jede
Kamera dein Gesicht wenn du protestieren
gehst und anschließend ruft die
Kommunistische Partei bei dir zu Hause
an und droht dir deiner Familie deinen
Freunden ganz unverhohlen mit
Konsequenzen und wenn du nicht
verprügelt wirst oder ins Gefängnis
gesteckt wird dann hast du vielleicht
keine eigene Wohnung dann verlierst du
den Anspruch auf deinen Job auf
Kinderbetreuung weil das Social credit
System weil das System es so will wie
groß liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wie
groß muss eigentlich die Überzeugung
sein die groß muss der Druck sein um in
einem Land wie China zu demonstrieren
denn den Menschen in diesem Land ist es
ernst liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen und
wenn wir jetzt nicht mehr so viel
darüber hören wie noch am Wochenende
über die Proteste dann liegt es vor
allen Dingen auch daran dass der
Überwachungsapparat dass der
zensur-apparat noch stärker ins Laufen
gekommen ist und wirkt und deshalb ist
besonders auch internationaler
Journalismus deshalb ist die Debatte die
wir auch hier führen die Öffentlichkeit
die Aufmerksamkeit für dieses Thema
elementar und deshalb haben wir als
Koalition genau auch diese aktuelle
Stunde hier heute auf die Tagesordnung
gesetzt erwartet wurde nicht zuletzt um
ein Zeichen an China zu senden dass wir
für euch sehen dass wir wissen dass es
Euch ernst ist und dass diese Proteste
nicht klein bleiben werden
das weiß im übrigen auch die
Kommunistische Partei deshalb fährt sie
ja alles auf was der
Unterdrückungsapparat zu bieten hat und
wir müssen uns hier darüber verständigen
was wir mit weiteren Eskalationen tun
wie gehen wir damit um genau dafür
brauchen wir einen Plan und auch in
diesem an diesem Punkt
ja an diesem Punkt holen uns Herr Wade
vor Sie haben ja schon ein bisschen
darauf in ihrer Rede rekoriert da holen
uns die Versäumnisse der letzten
Bundesregierung nein
das sage ich nicht Herr März wir haben
hier wir haben hier vor zwei Jahren
gestanden da saßen sie noch in der Mitte
da wo wir jetzt Gott sei Dank sitzen und
da hat der Kollege Wade holen und andere
Kolleginnen und Kollegen als wir genau
diesen Punkt gemacht haben es war gerade
das nationale Sicherheitsgesetz in
Hongkong verabschiedet worden
da haben sie hier gesessen als wir
gesagt haben wir müssten den EU
china-gipfel absagen weil wir zu diesem
Zeitpunkt auf dieser Grundlage nicht
einfach weitermachen können wie vorher
da lagen sie fast unterm Tisch vor
Lachen und vor Verächtlichkeit dieser
Forderungen gegenüber und wir holen
jetzt das nach was sie die letzten Jahre
versäumt haben und es wäre wichtig
gewesen dieses Problembewusstsein zu
erkennen es wäre wichtig gewesen eine
aktive Analyse der Abhängigkeiten der
notwendigen Resilienz zu schaffen
stattdessen haben sie das nicht gemacht
wir werden eine
ressortübergreifende China Strategie
vorlegen und wir werden dafür sorgen
dass die die die Fehler die im Grunde
bei diesem nicht akzeptieren der
Realität kommt frau Kollegin ich komme
zum Schluss nicht mehr gemacht werden
der Freiheitsdrang eines jeden
Individuums der ist stärker als jede
Ideologie
erhalten unglaublich wichtig für die
Menschen die sie nicht freihalten können
herzlichen Dank
Güdingen stellvertretende Vorsitzende
der FDP-Fraktion sieht diese Debatte
hier die aktuelle Stunde im Bundestag
zur Lage in China zur deutschen China
Politik auch als ein Zeichen an China
und die Protestierenden dort und sie
vermisst so hat sie gerade noch gesagt
das Problem Bewusstsein innerhalb der
Union zumindest hat sich vermisst was
die vergangene Legislaturperiode angeht
Alexander Rad waren ist am poold aus der
Unionsfraktion Mitglied der CSU
Landesgruppe
und die nehmen zu ja lassen wir mal
einen Teil weg
aber unabhängig davon sollten wir auch
wissen dass die Thematik wie wir sie
hier vortragen natürlich mehr oder
weniger zu Propaganda Zwecken dort
genutzt werden dass das alles vom
Ausland gesteuert wird und darum
konzentriere ich mich jetzt auf den
zweiten Teil dieser aktuellen Stunde die
Kinderpolitik
und wir erleben momentan ja
dynamische Entwicklungen in China bei
dem Protestierenden
und es kann auch außenpolitische Dynamik
geben wir wissen wie Ping sich geäußert
hat wie er sich selber positioniert hat
in seinen Reden und darum müssen wir in
unserer Kinderpolitik das Undenkbare
denken eine Dynamik kann jederzeit
auftreten und darum teile ich es dass
diversifizieren wichtig ist und
diversifizieren heißt gleichzeitig
keinen Bruch vornehmen
ansonsten können wir die Energie und
mobilitätswende von einem Tag auf den
anderen Tag einstampfen
Risiko reduzieren heißt Alternativen
schaffen
wenn wir jetzt Glück haben werden wir im
glaube ich 12 Anlauf diese Woche zieht
er vereinbaren können ratifizieren
können meine Damen und Herren
was verstehen wir denn unter
diversifizieren dass wir neue Partner
finden was heißt es denn konkret mit
mehr Kultur meine Damen und Herren das
nächste müsste das Merkur so Abkommen
sein dass wir dieses entsprechend
vorantreiben ratifizieren und heute und
heute recht es sich dass manchen in der
Ampel das chlorhühnchen wichtiger war
als eine Vereinbarung mit den USA der im
Flächen reduction act in der jetzigen
Phase ist ein riesen Problem für unsere
Wirtschaft meine Damen und Herren
Reziprozität sollte man nicht nur im
Mund führen meine Damen und Herren China
kann in dem Hafen in Hamburg investieren
umgekehrt ist es nicht möglich die
Rechte der chinesischen Unternehmen hier
ist stärker geschützt als die der
deutschen Unternehmen in China da ist
dringender Handlungsbedarf meine Damen
und Herren
und meine Damen und Herren
Alternativen heißt andere Partner in der
Welt finden
es hat ja der Kollege wadeful angedeutet
oder beide Kollegen haben sie angedeutet
dass die bisherige china-strategie über
die Medien kommuniziert wurde da stand
an erster Stelle Menschenrechte und
Klima es versuche ich das
zusammenzukriegen gestern haben wir
einen Vereinbarung mit entsprechenden
Katar bekommen und ihr
Bundeswirtschaftsminister hat es
gefeiert und hat sogar gesagt es ist zu
kurz ich stimme ihm ausdrücklich zu aber
wie kriegen sie es damit der Kritik der
Außenministerin in Sharm el Sheikh bei
Kopf 27 zu China zu den Golfstaaten
zusammen genau das Gegenteil ist
richtiges Handeln hier das
Wirtschaftsministers das unterstützt
aber sie in seiner Fraktion
boykottierendes
nächsten die diesen dezember findet eine
Konferenz in Riad statt der Golfstaaten
mit China Saudi Arabien mit
china-arabischen Welt mit China meine
Damen und Herren dort werden diese
Staaten ihre interessenvertreten ich
wäre dankbar Herr Staatsminister wenn es
ein Stück weit ein in die deutsche
Außenpolitik hinein käme dass wir unsere
Interessen in der Welt vertreten müssen
und nicht nur missionarisch unterwegs
sind
die beste Kinderpolitik meine Damen und
Herren und es hat keiner angesprochen
auch sie hat tritt hier nicht ist ein
starkes Deutschland in der Welt das
bedeutet es wirtschaftlich das bedeutet
es innovativ und das bedeutet es
militärisch das was bisher hier passiert
ist auf der durch die Bundesregierung
lässt der zum wünschen übrig es wurde
mehrfach die Pharmaindustrie
angesprochen die Rückverlagerung der
Pharmaproduktion aus China nach Europa
ich wäre froh meine Damen und Herren
wenn es nicht nur
das was bisher abgewandert ist sondern
wenn wir in Deutschland darauf setzen
würde innovative Technologie
zurückzuholen oder hier entsprechend zu
fördern ich sage Stichwort Gentechnik
ich habe einen Bericht bekommen dass ein
Bundesminister der Grünen ein Medikament
das in den USA gerade zugelassen wird
auf gentechnischer Basis zur Heilung von
Parkinson erklärt hat ja dann wollen wir
ein solches Medikament nicht in Europa
meine Damen und Herren das ist der
falsche Ansatz für eine gute
Außenpolitik eine starke Außenpolitik in
Deutschland und meine Damen und Herren
allerdings muss ich Ihnen sagen in der
jetzigen Phase weiß ich nicht ob das
größte Problem der deutschen Wirtschaft
die Energiekrise ist oder der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister bei dem
Bundeswirtschaftsminister habe ich
momentan meine größten bedenkung ob der
überhaupt in der Lage ist und in dieser
Phase entsprechend zu steuern besten
Dank
und für die SPD Alexander
Rathmann war der drittletzte Redner in
dieser aktuellen Stunde zum Thema China
und China Politik Frank Schwabe folglich
der vorletzte Sprecher für
Menschenrechte und humanitäre Hilfe in
der SPD-Fraktion dann sind verehrte
Damen und Herren in der Tat wir leben in
einer Welt das ist glaube ich auch
deutlich gewordene Debatte die sich neu
sortiert und bei allem schrecklichen was
wir gerade in der Welt erleben gibt es
aber eben auf Hoch auf Hoffnungsschimmer
mit dem man vielleicht gar nicht
gerechnet hat und ich finde diese
Proteste in China gehören entsprechend
dazu wir haben ja nicht nur den Eindruck
in den letzten Jahren gehabt dass ich
die Lage verschlechtert für
Menschenrechte Demokratie und Freiheit
in vielen Ländern der Welt sondern es
geht mir auch die Daten entsprechend her
aber wir haben eben diese Entwicklung
jetzt in China haben sie im Iran wir
hatten sie auch und haben Sie vielleicht
noch in Belarus in nordafrikanischen
Staaten Staaten und wir haben sie und
hoffentlich haben wir Sie demnächst noch
mehr in Russland das heißt es gibt
diesen Willen zu Freiheit es gibt diesen
Willen
zu Menschenrechten und es ist eben
nichts was vom Westen gesteuert ist
sondern es kommen von den Menschen
selbst es kommt aus den Gesellschaften
und es verdient unsere volle Sympathie
Respekt und unsere volle Unterstützung
und es ist eben und es ist auch in der
Debatte deutlich geworden es sind nicht
nur die corona-maßnahmen sondern es
kulminiert im Grunde genommen bei den
corona-maßnahmen es ist eine
Allmachtsfantasie ein totalitärer Staat
in China der glaubt alles am Ende regeln
zu können und mit den Menschen machen zu
können was sie wollen und es ist schon
wirklich in Form und böswillig das zu
vergleichen mit corona-maßnahmen in
einem demokratischen Staat wo man alles
behaupten kann und alles entsprechend
diskutieren kann
es gibt diese Repressalien diese
Unterdrückung der Menschen im Inland und
es gibt eben damit gepaart und das
erleben wir nicht nur bei China sondern
bei vielen anderen Ländern auf der Welt
auch auch eine Aggressivität nach außen
das war lange bei China anders aber das
ist mittlerweile leider eben auch so und
deswegen ist es richtig dass wir die
China-Politik gemeinsam neu justieren
das ist eine china-strategie gibt und ob
da was durchgestochen wird oder nicht am
Ende sein sie mal sicher wird eine
gemeinsame china-strategie dieser
Bundesregierung geben und ich glaube das
ist auch in der Debatte heute deutlich
geworden
wir haben parallel und die
menschenrechtspolitikerinnen und
Politiker sind ein bisschen müssten hier
rüberkommen einige von uns wir haben
parallel eine Anhörung drüben ein paar
ein paar Meter weiter und diese Anhörung
ist zum Thema systemischer Wettbewerb
Menschenrechte als integraler
Bestandteil der Weltordnung und ich will
zitieren ganz frisch Professor Heiner
Bielefeld der das sehr überzeugend noch
mal deutlich gemacht hat der gesagt hat
die Attraktivität der Menschenrechtsidee
ist ungebrochen und im Moment
symbolisieren weiße Blätter in China
diese ungebrochene Attraktivität der
Menschenrechte
China verletzt Menschenrechte wirklich
in epochaler und multiple Art und Weise
und auch das ist gerade schon gesagt
worden es ist falsch es ist falsch
Entwicklungspolitik an Entwicklung eines
Landes gegen Menschenrechte in Stellung
zu bringen es ist falsch Werte als
westliche Werte zu diffamieren weil
diejenigen die dort auf der Straße
stehen diejenigen Chinesen und Chinesen
die dort protestieren die meinen genau
die Menschenrechte die universellen
Menschenrechte die wir hier entsprechend
jedenfalls die meisten von uns auch
meinen wenn man über China redeten
Menschenrechtsverletzungen dann
kulminieren dann könnte man über viele
Beispiele reden über Hongkong Tibet und
vieles andere aber es kulminiert in der
Tat injean und deswegen ist es schon ja
fast symbolisch das ist am Ende zehn
Tote in nur rum chihan die bei einem
Feuer ums Leben gekommen sind die am
Ende jetzt diese Proteste ausgelöst
haben in den djang wo wir wirklich
Verbrechen gegen die Menschlichkeit
erleben in einer Art und Weise wie man
sich das in einem einer modernen Welt
eigentlich nicht vorstellen kann wo wir
Massen Inhaftierungen sehen von bis zu
einer Million Menschen wo wir Folter
sehen und die kulturelle Verfolgung von
Uiguren und anderen druckstimmigen
Muslimen wichtig ist im Umgang mit China
und das ist wahrscheinlich bei allen
Schwierigkeiten die wir sonst noch so
haben der schwierigste Partner in der
Welt wichtig ist dass wir in der Tat ein
unverstellten und einen klaren Blick auf
die Lage haben dass wir eine klare
Unterstützung geben und das sollten wir
jedenfalls in der Breite des Hauses
geben für die freiheitsliebenden in
China dass wir keinen Handel abbrechen
wollen aber wir wollen in der Tat
diversifizieren und wir wollen dass
menschenrechtliche Regeln zum Beispiel
im Rahmen von lieferkettengesetzen
angewendet werden in den
Handelsbeziehungen mit China und wir
brauchen und ich glaube das ist die
Lehre dieser Proteste einen
selbstbewussten Umgang mit universellen
Menschenrechten das war eine Schande das
China sich durchgesetzt hat im Moment
Menschenrechtsrat um eben nicht über den
Gang am Ende reden zu müssen aber
gleichzeitig haben wir zu sehen dass es
beim Iran mit deutlicher Mehrheit
gelungen ist dort tätig zu werden wir
haben gesehen dass die
Generalversammlung zu Russland eine
klare Mehrheit hat und ich glaube das
macht Hoffnung auf eine Welt wo
Menschenrechte Freiheit und Demokratie
eine Rolle spielen und wichtig sind und
es gibt sie eben diese Menschen die sich
nach Freiheit und Menschenrechten sehen
und in China sehen wir sie jetzt eben
auch und das verdient unseren vollen
Respekt und unsere volle Unterstützung
Frank Schwabe für die SPD-Fraktion in
der Aktuellen Stunde zum Thema China mit
die eröffnet wurde von Jürgen Trittin im
außenpolitischen Sprecher der Fraktion
Bündnis 90 die Grünen und eine der
stellvertretenden Vorsitzenden der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen schließt
diese Debatte jetzt auch ein jeschka ist
die letzte Rednerin
Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen als Zeichen des Protests genügt
in China heute mittlerweile ein weißes
Blatt Papier mehr gibt es nicht zu sagen
so bringen es die Protestierenden dort
auf den Punkt und wir erleben die seit
Tage eine sehr mutigende
beeindruckende Bewegung inzwischen in
zahlreichen Großstädten die größte seit
den Prozessen 1989 im Land die im
Tierheim Massaker blutig
niedergeschlagen wurden wie 1989 oder
auch bei der Demokratiebewegung in
Hongkong bei den krassen Menschen
verrechtsverletzungen an den Uiguren in
Tibet ja und auch von dieser Debatte
sollte die Botschaft an die Menschen
dort ausgehen wir haben euch nicht
vergessen
bei all diesen Entwicklungen kennt die
chinesische Regierung auch bei den
aktuellen Protesten wieder nur eine
Antwort Menschenrechtsverletzungen
massive Polizeipräsenz Festnahme und
Einschüchterungen Zensur und
Unterdrückung die chinesische
Bevölkerung sie leidet unter einer
gescheiterten impfstrategie unter der
Blockade von modernen mrna-impfstoffen
und die großflächigen und teilweise
wochenlangen harten lockdowns helfen
eben nicht gegen ommikron sie führen
viel mehr zu gesundheitlicher und
sozialer Not mit extremen ökonomischen
und sozialen Folgeschäden
Produktionsausfällen gestörten
Lieferketten die dann auch wiederum zu
niedrigsten Wachstumsrate seit Jahren
führen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen der
tragische Brand ich komme gleich zu
ihnen mit zehn Todesopfer bei dem die
Löscharbeiten durch den regidenden
Lockdown erschwert worden sind das war
der konkrete Auslöser der Proteste es
geht aber den Protestierenden eben nicht
allein nur um eine harte
unverhältnismäßige lockdown-politik die
BürgerInnen in China haben gespürt das
unter dem Vorwand der pandemiebekämpfung
die chinesische Führung ihre
Möglichkeiten zur Kontrolle bis in den
privatesten Bereich noch weiter
ausgebaut hat
und es muss endlich auch aufhören dass
immer wieder westliche Konzerne der
chinesischen Führung die Möglichkeit
lassen oder sie ihr gar geben ihren
umfassenden Überwachungsapparat immer
weiter auszubauen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen es ist
die Unzufriedenheit über die
wirtschaftlichen Probleme die
Jugendarbeitslosigkeit über die
Immobilien und Bankenkrise es ist der
Wunsch nach Freiheit nach Offenheit den
die Menschen aus ihren Herzen und Köpfen
auf die Straße
tragen und diese Sehnsucht die verstehen
wir die sehen wir und die unterstützen
wir
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen es sind
gerade die Rechtsextremen politischen
Kräfte die hier sonst so gerne die
Autokraten hofieren und verehren und
zugleich sehr erfolglos übrigens
versuchen eine Werte geleitete und
menschenrechtsorientierte Politik ins
Lächerliche zu ziehen wenn Sie nun den
Mut und die Motivation der Menschen in
China missbrauchen damit es in ihre
Pandemie verschwörungsmieten Propaganda
passt dann ist das nicht nur zutiefst
zynisch und dumm sondern das ist eine
Entnahme Instrumentalisierung dieser
mutigen Menschen
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen wenn ich
auch an die Debatten aus der Anfangszeit
der Pandemie denke und all die
Besserwisser die vorhersagten das
autokratische Regime in der Pandemie
doch handlungsfähiger sein dann kann man
nur sagen sie haben sich getäuscht nicht
erst die aktuellen Proteste in China
machen deutlich Regime die ihren
BürgerInnen Menschenrechte und freiheite
verwerten sind nur vermeintlich stabil
Autokratien sind eben nicht besser
geeignet um Lösungen zu finden sie leben
in einer permanenten Angst vor der
eigenen Bevölkerung und die Repression
und Unterdrückung sie sind Ausdruck von
Angst sie sind kein Zeichen der Stärke
wie viele Autokratien handelt China aber
nicht nur zunehmend in politisch äußerst
repressiv auch in der Außenpolitik kennt
die Kommunistische Partei vor allem eine
Richtung die militärischen Drohungen
gegenüber den Menschen in Taiwan werden
immer aggressiver die Lage im
Südchinesischen Meer wird schwieriger
und gefährlicher wir haben es in den
letzten Jahren einmal mehr als deutlich
erlebt ob bei der Klimakrise der
Pandemie den zahlreichen Kriegen es
betrifft auch unsere Gesellschaft unsere
Wirtschaft und unseren Alltag wenn die
regelbasierte internationale Ordnung und
ihre grundlegenden Werte verletzt werden
und auch deshalb dürfen uns die
steigenden Sorgen der Menschen in Taiwan
nicht egal sein
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen unsere
außenpolitische Antwort auf die
komplizierte Situation im Indopazifik
sie sollte aber nicht eine des
Gegeneinanders sein sondern eine des
Miteinanders und der Zusammenarbeit und
deshalb wollen wir diese auch Stärke mit
Staaten wie Japan wie Australien wir
Neuseeland und den vielen Partnerinnen
und Partnern in Südostasien auch das
wird die china-strategie der
Bundesregierung die Annalena baerburg
gerade erstellt beschreiben genau kommen
Sie bitte zum Schluss mit einem weiter
so der Vergangenheit sie wird die
Grundlage bilden für eine China-Politik
die Werte und Interessen nicht
gegeneinander ausspielt sondern in der
sie Hand in Hand zusammenlaufen vielen
Dank
[Applaus]
war das hier zur deutschen China-Politik
in der Aktuellen Stunde das Thema wird
uns natürlich noch länger beschäftigen
denn wir hier auch angeklungen ist wird
sich die Bundesregierung natürlich damit
auseinandersetzen müssen wie Deutschland
sich China gegenüber verhält